this episode brought to you by skill
share classes taught by expert
practitioners for your career or for
your passions the first 500 people who
sign up receive a free two-month trial
[Music]
hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic I
remember it so you don't have to my god
that was amazing even better than I
remember it I spared no expense
apologies but John Hammond is here to
convince us why there should be another
Jurassic Park see he just got done
showing us the first one I guess just as
spectacular as when I first saw it even
after all these years my god how did you
do it I'll show you now this is a
Jurassic Park movie no I am a Jurassic
Park movie but if we were to take just
one drop of the movies genius relax John
it's all part of the miracle of lazy
cloning no Jurassic Park movie by
creating the same thing over and over
with a drop of the original genius we
can have as many Jurassic park's as we
want remarkably remarkable the lack of
humility before great filmmaking that's
being displayed here staggers me Oh like
nah yeah I just want to relive my
nostalgia without questioning why I'm a
social media addict who does it like
change no no no let him talk I want to
hear everybody's viewpoint before i
automatically disagree with it I mean
don't you see the danger in what you're
doing here Jurassic Park is one of the
coolest most groundbreaking movies ever
made and you wield it like an alien vs.
predator single I don't think you're
giving us sequels enough credit haven't
you notice each sequel is getting Dumber
with every clone I'm to that thick Park
3 I put them both in the park
thanks man it's like they're Michael
Keaton movie from the 90s no one
remembers the paper no speechless
oh my life no desperate measures no Jack
Frost no much ado about nothing
oh one good cop no Pacific Heights no
multiplicity that's the one oh come on
each sequel has a ton of great scenes -
huh - great scenes that's what our
scientists figured out you only need two
great scenes to keep people coming back
lost world had the glass breaking and
the t-rex running in the city through
have the pterodactyls and the t-rex
fight and world had the opening and all
that ending but the t-rex I mean look at
the t-rex and then she's running around
in a high Hughes and then blue comes out
of now and before you know it the make
jumps after the water and then jump and
everybody's swap loading going goodness
gracious me
so by having only two good moments we
could have the same idiot characters
doing the same idiots things nobody
cares
stood on the shoulders of geniuses to
accomplish something as fast as you
could and before you even knew what you
had you patented it and package it and
slap down the plastic lunchbox and now
you're selling it you're selling it well
does anyone else feel weird that he's
getting the Ian Malcolm dialog cuz my
name is literally Malcolm how long is it
gonna take before doing the exact same
thing over and over it doesn't lead to
two great scenes anymore um I hate to
interrupt but what are your sequels
doing feeding round I knew it there two
bowing the original so now there's
nothing original left it's like the
terrible 90s would be with the awful CGI
deep rising though the relic lost us I
thought understand these shitty sequence
to make mommy happy you got so occupy I
think if you could you never bothered to
think if you shut it again literally
mouth I just don't know how this is
possible
well this is just like what happened
with today's movie Jurassic Park falling
obviously we all knew you were making
that comparison well do you know why
kids love the taste of cinnamon toast
crunch yes
will you tell us know
[Music]
it may have made a lot of money but
regressive world following Kingdom has
left a lot of viewers asking what the
heaping pile of dinosaur shit were they
thinking not only does it have little to
nothing new in it but the idiotic
decisions made in this movie are so
massive and so mind-blowing that you
feel like that one pilot and Return of
the Jedi too many of them along with
false advertising making it look like
the film was about the dinosaur is being
released on the public when it's really
just the last few minutes this duped
audiences pissed off critics and yet
still made a bundle at the box office
because dinosaurs are like dangling keys
to us just keep waving them in front of
our faces and we'll keep forgetting what
a lazy repetitive form of entertainment
they are so as long as there's still
people optimistic enough to have hope
for these movies oh God did those
sequels just belch up a hungover Jeff
Goldblum spared no expense we'll always
be here to review it let's take a look
at Jurassic world falling Kingdom the
film opens up with an inspiring idea
that no Jurassic Park film has ever
tackled before not just kidding it opens
with dinosaurs attacking people like
always
these guys are sneaking into the
now-closed park due to reconstruction
appealing tourists out of teeth as they
know this is a dangerous and illegal
mission so they smartly bring no weapons
at all
I don't know what this means what does
this mean
is this a gang sign are you in a gang
don't join the gang Hey look the t-rex
oh yeah it's not even really a big deal
anymore in the first one she always out
runs a jeep and the second one she can't
catch up to a crowd of people on this
one she can't catch up with Homer
Simpson's voice actor I'm a mother fan
who cares ok never laugh in a survival
film unless you want your obvious death
to be accompanied by
Boop quiet music shit's getting real in
this jurassic park
yeah we need epic latin gibberish to
frame the gigantic size of Jeff
Goldblum's ego I think we should allow
our glorious dinosaurs to be taken out
by the volcano as a dinosaur myself I
wish to be put out of my misery it looks
like a volcano is about to take out the
island of dinosaurs and the debate rages
whether or not it's ethical to save them
or let them die as well as the debate of
did Jeff Goldblum just read the script
and only now while saying the lines
realize how stupid it is I'm talking
about man-made cataclysmic change what
kind of change changes like death is
that really what I'm saying I'm a
scientist and that's what I'm saying
okay whatever dad meanwhile we cut to
the real heroes of this movie hipsters
oh you think I'm joking they have a
whole office of sjw's researching what
to be offended by next and good news you
have the whole movie with them as the
original owner of the park Claire played
again by Bryce Dallas Howard leads a
group of Chevy millennial ads to lobby
for the safety of the dinosaurs but they
get some bad news the committee has
result not to recommend any legislative
action regarding the D extinct creatures
on Isla Nublar they said this was
literally done just to shut Jeff
Goldblum up so as you can imagine this
is a real big blow to Clair or the music
indicates things are good
who said this movie was tone-deaf she's
brought two John Hammond number two
that's honestly what he is did you know
John Hammond had a super close business
partner he never talked about in any of
the other movies and it for some reason
you're confused as shit by that don't
worry this incredibly forced exposition
ome totally natural human talk will
clear things up we actually met one
seven eight years ago and you don't
remember a Hammond a Lockwood well the
custom lab in the sub-basement why don't
you run his foundation since college
yeah extracted the first DNA from
right beneath our feet you wanted
someone young and idealistic to spend a
fortune John Alfred Hammond father of
Jurassic Park but of course you know
that oh my god did you really just spell
out who Jon Hamm it is like the audience
is that stupid John Alfred Hammond but
of course you know that this is a
dinosaur but you already knew that these
are teeth but you already knew that this
is paper paper we're just talking how
people normally talk hey normally talk
him his partner is Ben Lockwood played
by James Cromwell
my god babe pig in the city wasn't kind
to him John said it best
these creatures don't need our
protection they need our absence that's
why we're flying into a ttle fist major
once more yep he wants to save them and
bring them to a new island to live in
peace because all the other times we
ever interfere with these bitches it
always turned out great
there was a tracking system in place in
the park radio frequency ID chips in
each dinosaur
I remember I know we're establishing how
bad the rioting is there is one that
poses a real challenge for us blue is
potentially the second most intelligent
piece of life on this planet we honestly
should have let her write the screenplay
of course there's only one person who
can connect with blue and that's her
trainer
Owen played again by Chris Pratt I was
Groot that shouldn't be too tricky to
get him on board seeing how those two
were an item from the last movie Oh
ghostbusters doing this you know that
dumb shell where they break up a couple
for absolutely no reason except to get
them back again in the sequel cuz new
ideas are for people who want to think
if there's anything twister has taught
us is that a divorced couple that
constantly acts like a divorced couple
should clearly be together
I left you you're so stubborn well look
at you how you're saving the world yep
that's the line that deserve the super
over-the-top laughs look at you how
you're saving the world
if blue is alive you're just gonna let
her die well yeah I got a band I'm
starting anyway called mouse rat I
really think it's got take off meanwhile
at a countryside so cliched they
actually put in a shooting star make a
wish
maybe they'll clone samuel l.jackson we
see where the real romance in this movie
lies hmm mr. Owen blue guess it does
have a nice ring to it so he surprises
her on the plane heading towards the
island I think you were gonna ever show
up well I have to change a million
things to account for another person
supplies rations and so forth but thanks
for surprising the asshole
don't worry though our duo of
self-righteous Lisa Simpsons will bring
the last more likely die riding a horse
than in a plane no I'm not because I
won't get on a horse my chances are zero
this is just like when we got the
argument of who's green play represented
the evils of capitalism better meanwhile
back at Lockwood's house oh yeah I'm
really scared something's gonna happen
and it's not just a fake out I don't
know I think one of those statues are
gonna move this is Maisie Lockwood's
granddaughter he cares for after his
daughter died in a car crash I don't
wanna back Queens English girl boss boss
wild animal it doesn't matter how
charming an actress you are honey you
will be the worst part of this movie you
have your mother's wicked sense of humor
do I look like her oh yes Oh took enough
notes to make sure I mean now what
strong genes ha ha ha
we're not playing the stuff there music
again it's a bug spray
Oh guys aren't gonna what bugs just
don't get it it's here I should be dead
by now right
oh he's afraid of the t-rex did you get
that did you get think he's afraid of
the t-rex we know we have to spell out a
lot for you so here it is again Oh she'd
be dead by now right
Oh frightfully witty they come across
the first whimsically beautiful dinosaur
a moment I'm just gonna guess and say
brontosaurus because that's always the
one they make whimsically beautiful it's
a weird thing your dinosaur movies show
very few kinds of dinosaurs we get a
load of this that's the first dinosaur
the dinosaur medic has ever seen
that's like a veterinarian never seeing
an animal why did you bring her yoga
should total money where there no other
dinosaur medics when this park was open
or did they just not have the badass
woke blogger spunk that she has things
could get hairy up these are powerful
sedatives one too many and she could
have respiratory failure also I'm not a
soft and witless is your comment implies
well at the risk of questioning the
towers of conventional cliche this movie
is breaking down I will ask the same
question I asked in van Helsing mmm
when does she get kidnapped fight the
good fight Wonder Woman they come across
the original car that fell with dr.
grant and Timmy in it
guess they moved the giant wall but
forgot the car as they locate blue but
open fire too early we leave son of a
bitch
cool so a dart they just said could
possibly kill a dinosaur just knocks out
Chris Pratt providing a comedic Lee
goofy moment when the volcano explodes
and he has to out numb his body to out
slither the lava what Chris Pratt
pretending to be mr. bean playing the
ground is literally lava supposed to be
funny
I believe being that close to actual
lava would probably leave you looking
like this throughout the rest of the
movie oh thank god these two are still
okay is this your ice - Clarence this is
your X are you sure that's notating
watch this down here good thing
instinctual dinosaurs are just as stupid
about staying away from lava go up you
dumbass go up go up Scooby you're making
fun of what a coward you are
wow what a pussy movie can kill tons of
people but it can't say the S word the
cementing of the pg-13 genius continues
yeah that'll work
oh okay no I thought that only worked
with coke machines and Dennis Rodman
shows what I know no no I have to stand
still slowly back away and then just
there blankly at it rather than take a
millisecond to step inside they can't
track you if you act really stupid but
the t-rex makes her big entrance which
we already saw so it's not a big deal
but man they try to make it one you know
she really is a drama queen she's like
the ultimate photo bomber I could
totally see a post on her Instagram
being like oh my god guys I just happen
to be roaring for no reason when a
volcano totally erupted what are the
chances right like in follow I'll eat
you buddy we then get to the film's
credit the only good suspenseful scene
we're clear and Franklin almost drown
but maybe I love it because Claire
Franklin almost drowned Pratt gets the
mound and they see the dinosaurs are
being taken captive well too bad at such
a long distance away and they couldn't
possibly walk there so they walk there
in seconds and find the men are
kidnapping the dinosaurs for their own
terrible means continue to be late-night
these Disney villains and talk about how
you're only interested in the money oh
and be sure to take an Evo trophy to add
to your evil collection even though a
friggin volcano is exploding in seconds
count
you're gonna feel that when you wake up
this will make a great necklace for my
woman suit our heroes goddamn jump from
an island on to the boat
while driving a truck and nobody seems
to notice
oh I cease because she wore a hat that
instantly disguises one of the most
famous faces the world had ever known
for a while oh isn't that the lady who
owned the park we were just sent to
pillage but she's got a new hat oh of
course yeah
then why is nobody recognizing those two
they don't have mind cloaking hats like
she does they were pretty high up in the
missions totem pole hell excuse me miss
we're in the middle of filming I'm gonna
need you to clear out critic it's me
did you see that random stranger wearing
a hat critic it's the logic of fallen
kingdom has not led me astray let me try
something
Malcolm when did you turn into a white
one okay I need a shot or something in
keeping with the film's fully
constructed toe and the dinosaurs that
we're trying to kill everybody and you
were supposed to be afraid of we're
immediately supposed to feel sorry for
now
[Music]
Wow it's like that incredibly smooth
transition they had in the first film
just think of it as kind of a big camp
it's a rollercoaster of emotion that's
not yet finished but you're writing
anyway
[Applause]
[Music]
as you may have noticed I'm a big fan of
a lot of artwork there's so many great
artists and so many great styles I love
collecting them I also like to draw a
bit myself but sadly I've been out of
practice for a while
thankfully there's a place where you can
pretty much learn anything you need and
that place is Skillshare calm Skillshare
is an online learning community with
more than 20,000 classes indesign photo
and more including as you would probably
guess drawing i used to be an
illustrator but so much time has gone
pass I don't always know all the new
technology thankfully there's classes on
there that can teach you practically
anything you need premium membership
gives you unlimited access so you can
improve your skills unlock new
opportunities and do the work you love
Skillshare also believes in accessible
learning and the price reflects them an
annual subscription with unlimited
access is less than ten dollars a month
ten dollars a month making it one of the
best deals you can find for online
education and since Skillshare is
sponsoring this video the first 500
people to use the promo link in the
description will get their first two
months free to try it out risk-free it's
been a long time since I can draw like
any of that but with Skillshare I can
get right back into it
there's plenty of classes with plenty of
opportunities so go to this link to
check it out the first 500 people to
sign up will receive a two month free
trial go to this link to start your
trial today it's never too late to learn
something
[Music]
[Applause]
beckon Lockwood's house Macy sees two
men in suits talking business
whoa this would entice any
seven-year-olds attention gotta check
this out artists have created a direct
descendant the animal that took down
Jurassic world
it follows human in command ah you're
making another time to soar based on the
one you couldn't control before that
destroyed an entire park
I see no problems here proceed mazie
tries to let her grandfather know what's
going on they're going to sell the
dinosaurs bring them in sure you
misunderstood I know what I had gone
crazy it's way past your bedtime you
were just like this the first time you
were this age our here must find Zia and
tried to help her fix up blue who was
injured luckily take over for Claire
oh my god is in my mouth
she says blue needs a blood transplant
and the only one that'll work is of
course from the t-rex okay I don't know
much about dinosaurs and judging by the
fact she's never seen one I don't think
she does either but he's getting the
blood from two very different animals
the same if a cat is injured with blood
from a lion work just as well
Chaplin what do you think oh the tea
rice of course wakes up they don't
realize they can just stay behind her to
be safe
and they attempt a crazy escape to get
the blood back meanwhile back at
Lockwood say I guess big surprises made
dr. Wu is helping them weaponize the
dinosaurs blues DNA will be part of the
next Indo Raptors makeup when did this
guy go from just the person next to the
dinosaur eggs to the world's biggest DNA
splicing supervillain I'll tell you
exactly when there's not that nod was up
to something
of course they figure out that Maisie
knows about their super illegal
diabolical plan so they give her a
timeout keep her in there
and keep the door locked now you think
about how weaponizing endangered species
can benefit you Hey look they like each
other again yeah seeing how their
chemistry made no sense it was out of
nowhere in the last movie I guess it
makes sense to do it once more but wait
this isn't moving starting to see
hipsters painfully forest rump joke take
your own damn samples
whoa whoa whoa I'm sorry Stephen Colbert
SNL and countless Internet means you
need to retire
Jurassic world has won the battle of
political commentary and here everybody
thought fair nine eleven nine would be
the field to bring Trump down okay
nobody thought that but nevertheless
Jurassic world has beaten you to the
punch oh thank you so much writer of
monster trucks
you have keeping us of police forget the
dinosaurs to Lockwood's house somehow
not making any noise for Lockwood or his
servants to hear hey I guess if they
made this dinosaur dungeon and
auctioning house under his nose all this
time they must just have really quiet
workers and think of the dinosaurs in
their cages
[Music]
doesn't it be fatty wants to hunt
everybody who made this hates the first
movie but luck would finally finds out
hey I guess he does have a little bit of
a brain but not too much did you really
think you could get away with it pick up
that farmer I want you to call the
police oh hey Malcolm what are you up to
oh well I've spent years and years
building a quieren to auction off
weaponized killer whales I've hired a
lot of people to transport them and the
bidder should be amazing no no Malcolm
this won't do it all I need you to call
the police and turn yourself in well I
guess there's no other way around it
no not at all I'm sure once I let all my
accomplices know they'll gladly turn
themselves in - I think that goes
without saying thank you for setting me
straight and bringing my life to a
crashing halt absolutely it's the least
I could do
wait could I kill you
oh man I guess you're right okay I'm
placing the call right now spit-spot
hello police yeah I've got a whale of a
tale for you he's a good kid
so anyway the bad guy doesn't call the
cops and kills Lockwood meanwhile Owen
and Clara found out and captured who oh
you should have stayed on the island
grab him by the pussy man build a wall
to keep him locked up
so okay they're locked up in the house
the auction for the dinosaurs is about
to begin
surely this must be the opening of the
third act nope we're only at the halfway
point yeah there's still a ton of this
movie left Christ this film winning
faster if you just killed him instead of
explaining your plan like a James Bond
villain
I saved these animals you betrayed a
dying man for money Claire I admire your
idealism I never ever ironically uses
the trick that the Raptors used in the
Jurassic Park parody from The Critic
proving this pretty much is a parody of
a parody and even then it seems
pointless because she climbs out of a
window a moment later well why did you
just have her climb out her bedroom
window to save time no wonder we still
have an hour left stop writing pointless
shit dog
God Delia by the way there is a small
child climbing up your building you may
want to get that looked at so the
auction begins as all the world's most
darkly dressed supervillain leaders come
to bid on the flintstones garage sale
the ankylosaurus is a herbivorous and
quadruped ed this is one of the largest
are
dinosaurs the ankylosaurus is wearing
our Late Cretaceous fall look which
seems to say to on lookers I give
pointed conversation sassy
Owen has an idea though for how to get
out of their cell that thing's gonna
kill us totally gonna kill us
oh don't worry I'm sure there's yet
another cartoon dumbell scene that'll
save everybody they come across Maisie
and quickly earn each other's trust my
name is Claire what's yours
Maisie maybe you don't good Maisie
number two Lockwood and I always thought
as a we're middle name I mean well they
bring out the leftover Rex and tell them
it's not being bid on because it's only
a prototype then why are you showing it
are you trying to cement your place in
the ever-growing dinosaur auction market
I feel like you got the seal on this for
a while
20 million what do you want they bid on
it anyway which once again is a
pointless scene because Owen comes in to
stop again you could have cut that and
not miss shit
there's clearly blame on both sides for
this some of you are mighty fine people
of course dumbass goes into the cage of
gets the best thing to call it is coke
three asaurus two one else get a tooth
for his tooth collection
what follows is amazingly not the
stupidest thing in the movie she smiled
at the camera it's official we're in a
weird out video we are seconds away from
this thing just straight-up talking kids
what has one arm and is you know but
don't think on top of that you're not
giving a WoW moment - we used to make
real movies we then get the dumbest most
pointless twists in all the film and on
top of that it comes out of nowhere the
bad guys corner our heroes and floor no
reason just starts talking about this
you have no idea what she is Lockwood
never had a grandchild he just wanted
his daughter back he made her again mm
yeah that's pretty stupid right she's a
clone what's the point of that it
doesn't connect to anything and despite
being I guess a few clues nobody could
have guessed this because it doesn't tie
into any of the characters motivations
why even tell him that just shoot them
at acre in fact what tell me see that
what did he think was honestly gonna
happen after he let her know that's
right she's a clone now Maisie come here
good girl good girl yeah you were faced
by that all were you yeah no not only
what some ice cream well it's an ice
cream yell be nice yeah yeah you're a
clone right shoot them
Franklin saves Xia from the evil dr. Wu
God that still sounds weird and who
gives a shit Soros tries to hunt down
our heroes as the rest of the movie
pretty much just turns into Yoshi's
mansion boy does wipe a nice killing
machine is kind of a dumbass
she can't even find them when they're
literally under her nose and even when
she does she's so goddamn clumsy you'd
swear the scream killer gave her
stalking lessons oh yeah
you sure heightened sense of smell to
completely miss that they were right in
front of you a door oh well can't get
beyond that I guess she's the signs
aliens been great idea leave the two
larger meals who are trapped behind and
chase after the smaller morsel running
away what this thing is gonna have some
serious buyer's remorse
Claire's leg is busted up bad so she
urges Owen to go and save Maisie can't
leave you here remember I dumped you
the choir music comes back again totally
warranted for such a giant epic image
like Oh rapture and we see the kid who
figured out this giant evil conspiracy
boarded the bad guys at every turn and
even managed to outsmart a prehistoric
predator it's now the Cobbers for safety
it's one of the bugs of cloning they can
find ingenious escape routes along
dangerous ledges but think bedsheets are
indestructible bomb shelters but
honestly it's almost as bad as our bug
with cloning dinosaurs or even when they
find their prey they just slowly wave
their fingers in front of them rather
than attack like every other instance
what I'm trying to say is science is
stupid but oh it comes in two shooter
but it doesn't seem to work so he hay
goes to protect the kid B runs out the
door behind him C grabs the kid and
takes her with him through the door
behind him or D leans up against the
wall like a seven-year-old who's dumb
enough to hide under bed covers yeah I'm
convinced this whole thing is a
big-budget Johnny karate episode blue
comes in to save the day so now they can
go out the door or the window yeah
that's um okay it's not as safe as the
bedsheets but it'll have to do Claire
somehow climbs the windows as well
despite having a busted leg a second ago
and distracts the soon to be forgotten
thesaurus long enough for Owens true
love to take her down
what's the matter feeling blue oh but it
looks like a toxic gas is going to kill
off what's left of the dinosaurs unless
they free them with that giant red
cartoony button Wow the designers really
took opening a door very seriously but
they decide not to as in one of the few
adult moments of the movie they realize
their love for animals it's not worth
the countless loss of human life the
mixing of two worlds damned I had to so
just close the door oh you only have a
big red button to open the door not a
big red button to close the door if only
there was a big red button for the big
red button who does I guess
and what's her dumbass reason for
dooming mankind their life
[Music]
they're about to kill a lot of little
kids like you too
dumbass so it's Dino spring break as
they're all set loose and the bad guy
gets his comeuppance from what used to
be the coolest character in the movies
but now it just feels like Porky Pig
ending a Looney tune short looks like
Blu has to part ways to tell that crazy
kid thanks whenever I eat up up a Girl
Scouts I'll always think of her so yeah
this movie ends with Dinosaurs getting
ready to eat a mankind would have kind
of been cool if this was the movie
it's almost as confusing is where the
hell did this one come from was she
captured in a sea tank it also opened up
with the door or did she literally swim
all the freaking way to a California
beach and what's even more confusing is
apparently we're supposed to have
sympathy for our adorable angel of death
but all I can think about is Malcolm
McDowell describing Michael Myers these
are the eyes of a psychopath but in the
end Jurassic world falling Kingdom pulls
it all together because of this
incredibly spelled out lesson which goes
against this incredibly spelled out
lesson these creatures were here before
us and if we're not careful they're
gonna be here after you which doesn't
really match up with this incredibly
spelled out lesson these creatures don't
need our protection they need our
absence but at least we can all agree
but soon they're gonna have to watch
them go extinct we're not if people like
you make a difference it's like when we
have a lot of messages that say opposite
things we're incredibly complex or
really transparent we couldn't decide on
what message we wanted this movie's
awful
I'll give credit that the effects are
pretty good much better than some of the
previous ones I also give credit that it
is kind of us so bad it's good kind of
flick I mean they just constantly throw
stupid shit after stupid shit at you
it's relentless of the amount of dumbest
bits of your face but that's not what
people wanted they wanted a real
Jurassic Park film one that's fun but
also made some semblance of sense and
gave us something new and different
instead we pretty much got the worst of
all the other Jurassic Park movies all
the weaknesses none of the strengths
everything that didn't work in those
past films is showcased in this one it's
stupid it's corny is pretentious and
it's preachy
even though half of the time it doesn't
know what it's preachy about I don't
care if it made money to me this is a
Jurassic flop now with the next genetic
Park sequel everything is correctable
John box office is a matter of sheer
will well it's still a flea circus it's
all an illusion when we have a
participative you never had a script
that's the illusion we were overwhelmed
by the first film but now all that
matters is not having another alien
covenant welcome to jurassic covenant
I'm the Nostalgia Critic end I'll see
you at Jurassic world The Legend of
Curly's gold
[Music]
[Applause]
you
[Music]
look at you how you're saving the world
[Laughter]
hey guys dog walker here doing the
charity shout on this week we are doing
homes for our troops homes for our
troops as a privately funded nonprofit
organization they build and donate
specially adapted custom homes
nationwide for severely injured post
9/11 veterans this is done to enable
them to rebuild their lives most of
these veterans have sustained injuries
including multiple limb amputations
partial or full paralysis and/or a
severe traumatic brain injury these
homes restore some of the freedom and
independence our veterans sacrifice
while defending our country and enable
them to focus on their family recovery
and rebuilding their lives this
organization built these homes where the
veteran chooses to live and continues
its relationship with them after home
delivery to assist with rebuilding their
lives if you look at their site on their
YouTube channel you can not only see the
great people who served our country but
also the great people making sure they
get all the love and support they
deserve click on the link and discover
how you can show your gratitude to so
many brave soldiers
you
[Music]